Let's take a look at value proposition.
Value proposition is not something you're building in isolation.
While the value proposition is about solving a customer problem or need,
it really consists of 3 components.
The easy one for most entrepreneurs to talk about is what product features you have
or what product services you're providing.
But there's actually 2 more important components to value proposition:
What gain are you creating for customers?
And what pain are you solving for them?
Alexander Osterwalder, when he drew the business model canvas,
really emphasized this. It's not just about your product.
And especially if you come from a technical background, it's really easy to say,
"Oh, look at all these features."
And if you find yourself doing that, you need to complete the sentence and say,
"Yes, but here's what we make people be able to do better,
"and here are the problems we solve for them."
So the real goal of you figuring out the value proposition
is understanding what we call the minimal viable product.
You're trying to figure out, "Now that I kind of understand my product and service
"and what I'm gaining for customers and the pain I'm solving,
"what's the smallest possible feature set I could be shipping on day 1
"that solves these pains and creates gains for them?"
And this really is an interactive process
because there is no way, no possible way, sitting in your office you could figure this out.
And the default for great engineers and great entrepreneurs is,
"Oh, I understand customers' problems and needs,
"so don't worry about it. We'll just spec the entire product on day 1."
Your real goal here is to figure out what's the smallest thing you could build and develop
that actually gets you users or sales or whatever
and get out to market as quickly as possible.
And so the goal of you getting out of the building for value proposition
is understanding gains and pains so you can figure out what's the MVP,
or minimum viable product.